good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are in the world thank you
so much for joining us you are joining
the co vid 19 webinar how a novel
infectious disease impacts local global
and future health this is brought to you
today by the Yale alumni association
shared interest groups my name is
Stephanie double I'm a director for the
shared interest groups at the yaa we are
doing this webinar in partnership with
the Yale alumni helps network the Yale
School of Public Health and Yale Health
so we're gonna hear from a number of
experts today our chair of the Yale
alumni Health Network is dr. Jamie wells
Yale College class of 96 jamie has
published over 400 articles on as a
director of medicine for an educational
advocacy nonprofit in support of
evidence-based medicine and science and
she writes speaks and it interviewed as
a medical expert in multimedia platforms
she is currently adjunct professor at
Drexel University's School of biomedical
engineering science and health systems
which is the nation's first program in
pediatric engineering without further
ado I'm going to turn this over to the
amazing dr. Jamie Wells thank you so
much Stephanie and yaa and all of the
participants on the panel today we're
very excited we hope a serious tone but
be able to enjoy this a bit and calm
some fear is a swage any panic that's
for sure and our goal is to increase the
information debunk amidst in this hour
the yellow of my health network or yawn
our mission is to break down silos and
the health related disciplines to spur
innovation so albeit from a biomedical
engineering perspective medical
practitioners epidemiologists health law
health policy we want to break down
those silos be a nexus between the
disciplines because it's those knowledge
gaps that sometimes perpetuate
misinformation and also can be a key
source of innovative solutions so I am
thrilled that we have a wonderful panel
today hopefully we will do some good in
furthering the spread of wonderful
information and modes and methods for
you all to participate because I know
people are chomping at the bit at ways
they can help and everybody can pitch in
to do so so without further ado before I
kick it off to my speakers and my
wonderful speakers today we have held
sold out if Yanis held a sold-out event
in New York City with Dean Kaman we're
planning on doing future other in-person
events I'm very hopeful there will be
down the line but they will resume again
and we also will be doing because of the
high high demand today a recurring
series on these kinds of things and
using remote learning and webinars to do
so first I'm gonna introduce the
speakers they're gonna speak for about
five minutes each and then we are gonna
open to questions so feel free to
utilize the question bar to do that so
without further ado one of our rock
stars today is on the front lines of the
current crisis dr. Cindy Howe is a Yale
graduate she is an infectious disease
physician she serves as the infection
control officer of her health system at
Jefferson Health New Jersey so she is in
direct contact with the Department of
Health
creating policies that are changing
every minute it seems these days as she
is an active practitioner she dr. ho is
also physician champion for New Jersey
Hospital Association's antimicrobial
stewardship stewardship collective and
an advisory board member of the sepsis
alliance her knowledge is vast in this
field and she is going to address what
it is that she does and what the
psychosocial effects of kovat 19 are so
dr. ho take it away hello everybody I
want to break the ice and give you a
virtual fist bump oh and good morning
good afternoon good evening wherever you
are it's um it's great to be here and
thank you so much for Jamie wells for
the invite and and the yellow Network
and everything so as Jamie said I am an
infectious disease physician
and I do infection-control for Jefferson
Health New Jersey and also our inventory
sites with Jefferson Medical Group
having said that today what I'll say is
basically kind of my opinion and does
not reflect any of those two entities
and and I really am on the front lines
so our institution like many of yours
have probably received kovat 19 patients
or what we call rule-out koba 19
patients so I really am on there on the
frontlines but the truth is that there
are many frontlines and in this effort
and today I really want to talk a little
bit about the psychosocial impact of
copán 19 because I've really found that
it impacts everyone and people that you
may not have even considered before and
I guess I'll start with the health care
set setting you know the situation is
already very stressful when you look at
things maybe maybe look at the TV or
media too often there's a certain
threshold where you you need to get
information and of course a reputable
information at the same time you can't
do too much because then you get into
this state of worry and anxiety about
everything and I found that that can
sometimes occur to the healthcare
workers our own doctors our nurses even
text the environment surface workers
everyone because you know there is a
worry in in cases where a patient comes
in and they're being kind of rolled out
for Kovan 19 and the posts of the people
is that room they're really concerned
whether they're inadvertently going to
bring home anything to potentially
expose their own families and sometimes
what you might hear of over the states
is whether the health care worker might
even be separating their own families
and and they might relocate some some of
their their parents or their children to
elsewhere because they're just really
concerned and I think for those of us
who work in whatever health setting it's
it's an opportunity unlike any other
where every day we have to ask each
other how are you and
you know to take a sense of the pulse of
the people but it's
it's an intense environment to begin
with and perhaps only going to become
more intense as we try to tackle and
manage the everyday people that come
into our healthcare settings let alone
when there might be the potential for
even more serious cases of the Copa 19
patients and and then when you talk
about the healthcare setting there's the
patients themselves and I'm not just
referring to the people who are in
strict isolation just imagine if you
were quarantine not in the large
confines of your apartment or your house
or condo or wherever you may live but
really in a room in the hospital setting
and you're quarantined for however long
until the medical therapy is done and so
you know we have to consider the
patients who are infected whether there
is a role for any kind of behavioral
health specialists a psychologist a
psychiatrist and to check in with the
patient about how they feel those who
are infected and honestly it's also
those who are not infected you know
there may be settings where there are
nursing homes it's not opportunity for
those who have been fortunate having
kids or grandkids or even if you're an
adult it's a chance to write a note a
simple hello a simple card to those who
are confined because they can't have
visitors it's very common these days for
health care setting sightings not to
have any visitors just imagine the the
thought of the fact that it's just
isolating to be isolated and these are
the times where we need to reach out to
each other to improve our our perhaps
our unknown needs from a psychological
standpoint and it's also a time for
those those of us who are maybe not
directly in the care of health patients
to be involved in other ways that each
of us can find a way somehow whether
it's to help those who are not in school
that might need school lunches or school
breakfast or even whatnot and a chance
for congregate settings to really help
out in community and whatever way that
we can
you hear many stories of this for where
it's simply neighbors helping neighbors
really that in this day and time when
it's strongly suggest as a social
distance what can we do for our
neighbors that they may not be infected
at all but they're elderly do they need
help with day-to-day activities do they
need help with groceries there's just so
many things that I think are so
important that I had never previously
thought about in a situation like this
at least in my lifetime you know that
this is hopefully once-in-a-lifetime but
there are there are many things that
each one of us can do to improve the
psycho psychological needs of each one
of us and even if it's admitted or not
admitted each of us has a pole set has
to be looked into thank you so much
doctor we're gonna circle back to you
but we want to introduce our next
panelist dr. Saad Omer who is the
inaugural director of the Yale Institute
for glow for a global health professor
of medicine and epidemiology at Yale
University in the School of Medicine and
the School of Public Health and he's
going to do us all a favor to explain
what epidemiology is because you're
hearing a lot of the public is hearing
about epidemiologists believe it or not
we all have different perspectives when
we're in medical practice versus
epidemiology but hopefully they are
never maillot aligned in terms of our
pursuits so he's going to expand on that
a little bit he is extensively studied
and done research on efficacy and safety
of maternal and/or infant influenza
pertussis polio measles and pneumococcal
vaccines he is experimented and done
trials in drug regimens to reduce
maternal to child transmission of HIV so
he is quite a knowledgeable viral hunter
I would say and so I'm going to flip it
over to you dr. Omer and he is going to
speak to how we got here and where we're
going so thank you so as it's well known
that the virus was initially identified
in Wuhan China some of the initial cases
from this
seafood market but we're not sure that
it's actually the the zoonosis event the
event of this virus jumping from an
animal and I'll come to that in a second
two humans came from that specific
market but there was usually initially
that you identify a cluster of people
there we think a single event of a virus
jumping from an animal to human happened
in early December or late November by
Iran mid to late December
they started the Chinese authorities
local authorities started seeing an
uptick in pneumonia cases unusual
pneumonia cases and by December 31st
they identified the World Health
Organization this is a and then you know
the rest is history in the world has
been seeing these cases emerge and
explored and introduced into I think the
last count was between hundred and fifty
and hundred and sixty countries now have
an importation of this virus or they
have the virus identified in these
countries the US unfortunately of the
353 ka thought of two hundred
fifty-three thousand cases a little over
three hundred fifty-three thousand cases
the u.s. is the third highest has the
third highest number of cases among all
countries followed by China Italy and
Italy and the way that our outbreak is
going we're likely to surpass
Italy fairly soon we currently have 235
thousand and five hundred reported cases
as of 1144 a.m. this morning the cases
obviously they're reported in in batches
and we are likely to see more cases here
hardware that this virus come from it's
a bad virus we know bats have a lot of
viruses out there that often jump to
other species we think that it came
through an intermediate species and it's
not a direct transmission to human and
so so that's what we know what what the
intermediate species wars
as you saw I used my comp 19 just so
everybody and and so so yeah so we have
we know that this virus came from a
mammalian originates from a bad virus
that went passed through another another
species
so how infected but how transmittable
this virus is so the way we measure the
way we have we quantify the transplant
ability of a virus is called R 0 or R
naught which is a simple concept it is
you know if you go into a population
where nobody is immune and if you
introduce one case how many different
individuals will be infected from that
one case and the R naught or r0 of this
virus is between 2.2 and 2.7 the
estimates vary early in the outbreaks
just to give you compare comparison
measles is way more effective for
example it's 12 to 15 SARS is close to 2
between 2 and 3 and Ebola was 2 in terms
of this value of on average how many few
second Rica's has appeared if you
introduced one case so it is
transmittable it has a relatively short
serial interval in a sense that the
average time between two successive
cases and therefore it has a pretty high
doubling time of the outbreak in a sense
that you as if a transmission takes hold
the increase happens rather quickly once
you have testing and that's what you're
seeing we know that there's human to
human transmission we go on the good
news side we from the limited data that
are available there is little evidence
of a vertical transmission of this virus
but we do know that there is evidence of
asymptomatic transmission but it's
likely that the transmission even if
it's happening a couple of
before two to three days before the
symptom onset that's why we sometimes
quarantine asymptomatic people so
quarantine is for asymptomatic people
isolation is for symptomatic people so
that's a difference in terminology
that's why we sometimes quarantine
people even when they're asymptomatic
but most of the transmission still
occurs right after the onset of symptoms
so just to put that in context so this
is the big picture of the virus we know
that we have cases there is plenty of
evidence there is well-established
community transmission of this virus in
the u.s. the good thing is that you know
it's not that we are helpless observers
in the face of this unfolding event
there are a lot of things we can do both
as individual and as a society even
short of having a vaccine which is
obviously the end game of controlling
this outbreak and there are efforts
going on there so personal hygiene etc
hand-washing has it's based on evidence
it does reduce the probability social
distancing staying at home previously
you know when folks you know most it's
now are asking everyone to stay at home
but previously the recommendation was to
stay at home if you have symptoms so
those who are who don't have the option
of not staying at home like health care
workers then going in everyday even they
have the restriction of staying at home
in most places if they have symptoms at
etc and and these are some of the
strategies at the societal level we can
head into what societies can do as they
strike a balance between the
epidemiological advantages and social
impact of some of these restrictions
because both of these things are
important so I'll pause here and would
love to thank you so much and for the
audience we're going to go into a
question answer mode after we introduce
our final speaker is just so we need so
everyone's informed as to the different
perspectives and approaches and we get a
more comprehensive view of this issue so
we will get into transmission testing
treatment a lot of questions coming in
with regard to those things
asynchronous geographical
isolating different things we're gonna
hit so before we do that we have one
final speaker so I'm not gonna say
saving the best for last because all of
our speakers are rockstars today but dr.
Dorothy Ann Van Rhine is the chief of
employee health at Yale University she
trained in primary care
started at Yale health treating patients
in acute injury and occupational health
she has been the chief of the employee
health department for the University for
many years served on numerous university
level committees including the
biological Safety Committee she chairs
the infection control committee for Yale
Health has interested in sue anodic
disease and the intersection of animal
and human health
and has an extensive background and she
is going to speak now about what she's
doing and what they're doing in the
community up in New Haven so thank you
dr. van Ryan Thank You Janie yeah so my
role is the chief of employee health we
are very involved with the reporting and
the contact tracing of the cases in the
Yale community so this week is a very
different situation than it was about
two weeks ago when we didn't have any
cases New Haven and like most of us I
think we've been very busy trying to
identify new cases and with them and do
some contact tracing one of the
surprising things that's come out of
this is that there's been a really
wonderful amount of collaboration
between all of the schools at the
University so Yale health Yale School of
Medicine School of Epidemiology the
nursing school in addition the hospitals
yellow Haven Hospital and also the New
England Medical Group which is a private
group associated with the University
we've all really come together and to
respond to this pandemic and people are
sharing protocols they're looking at
staff they're looking at where they can
redeploy staff they're looking at
student trainees who may be able to be
sent to various places to do roles that
would be applicable to their level of
training so it's it's been a great
community response in terms of trying to
help everybody and keep the community
safe
currently what we're doing now is
although many of the health departments
have actually given up on contact
tracing we still have we have many cases
here but we don't have as many as New
York City for instance so we're still
working with the Department or with the
School of Epidemiology and trying to
look at the high-risk contacts of the
known cases so that we can reach out and
identify them and ask them to self
isolate so that's from one of our main
focuses for the last week
currently epidemiology has a number of
student volunteers that are helping them
in this effort and it's been a really
wonderful collaboration we've also been
working with yellow Haven Hospital to
set up drive-through testing sites so I
think everybody's heard that testing was
somewhat of a challenge initially
because it could only be done through
the State Department's of Health and
there were a limited number of test kits
we actually have a better situation now
although I think it could still be
improved but now that we have some
commercial partners we can do more
testing and so we have several
drive-through testing sites and recently
the end of last week we took one of the
Yale employee parking garages and we've
turned that into a drive-through testing
site and the hospital has some in other
locations over the state as well we do
hear that there's supposedly going to be
a point-of-care test on the horizon at
some point but it's a little tuna soon
to say how that will be used and when it
would be available to us one of the
other things the university is doing
that's really exciting is we've taken
one of the sections of the gym we call
it the Landman Center and we're setting
up an auxilary treatment center there
and we'll have space for anywhere
between 25 and 50 patients to start out
and these would be patients that were
not sick enough to be hospitalized but
for whatever reason not able to go back
to their homes to be monitored so that's
been a huge effort in terms of
mobilizing staff and equipment and space
and getting set up we have a big
partnership with the Environmental
Health and Safety folks at the
University they've been training us and
how to use the personal protective
equipment so that all the hell
coworkers know how to use it because
it's not enough to have the equipment we
actually have to make sure that we put
it on properly and take it off properly
so that we don't contaminate ourselves
or another patient and they've been
working with us on deacon and
decontamination techniques and also
because of the shortage of some of the
respirator masks they've been able to
procure a couple types of respirators
with a hood that can be decontaminated
and reused so that is a very promising
situation for us I'm going to say thank
you so much and I wanted the viewers to
know that we already talked about I feel
like with these it's like you're a I'm
not a professional anchor but I do want
to get everybody's questions we're
getting inundated with questions which
is a wonderful thing so we want to
answer as many as we possibly can so all
of the speakers already know if I
interrupt them it's it's meant to be
polite but so one of the first things I
want to pivot to is transmission I'm
getting a lot of questions with respect
to their reports that there are
respiratory droplets and then there's
also the fecal-oral route are there
different strains with respect to that
what did dr. Omer mean by vertical
transit transmission how do we put this
into context of SARS and MERS in terms
of is this going to be a one-off so if
we can have each of the speakers maybe
starting in the order that we did dr. ho
with regard to transmission people want
to know can they get it in a pool how is
it transmitted on surfaces versus
elsewhere so if we can touch briefly on
that that would be wonderful followed by
dr. Amer and any additional thoughts
thereafter
sure so the basic two routes which
explains some of the things that all of
us have been asked to do is you know
when you have to cover your coffee
you're basically covering the nature of
the the cloth from going outwards into
the six-feet Brown and so if you think
about it that way then one of the ways
that it can be spread is droplet so if I
had if I were infected and I coughed
into my hand and I kind of put it on a
surface and then somebody else was very
nearby such as on public transit maybe
somebody else could
could get that as an example so there's
a droplet spread and then there's the
contact spread so and this is prolong
contact without what they call the PPE
or the personal protective equipment
this is this is a lot of the themes that
you've heard probably all over the
states of health care workers pleading
for PPE
for the purposes of protecting
themselves when they're are taking care
of those who have the köppen 19 there
are potentially other routes that the
virus has been found such as when koban
19 patients historically or classically
you think of them having respiratory
symptoms they can also have GI or
gastrointestinal types and symptoms such
as a domino pain and diarrhea and this
is one modality of why feces are thought
to be a potential for spread and so
sometimes your local county may suggest
having a separate bathroom if there are
other people that live in the same
household and then you know sometimes
it's not really possible and and so
there are standardized ways of cleaning
and a Froome from the vine bun will
protect and protective agency type kinds
of recommendations such as with bleach
and so forth and so these are some of
the considerations of the questions that
you and asked dr. Elmer I think dr. who
covered into appropriately wonderful in
terms of seasonal seasonal shifts we're
getting a lot of questions of which I'd
love everybody to read be able to
interpret a crystal ball but what are we
looking at in terms of the next few
months is this society going to return
to normal are we going to be semi normal
ish for a couple month period of time is
there any kind of projection in terms of
how these pandemics tend to go in terms
of that so these are two separate
questions so there's a seasonal shift
and then how long can we be there so I
can answer the seasonal shift and then
sort of if there is time I can answer
the second question as well because
they're they're separate questions
so for seasonal so it's not an unfounded
perspective there are a lot of myths out
there this is not one of them it's that
it is that
there is genuine uncertainty about how
this virus will behave and here's the
here's what we know from other viruses
so they have respiratory viruses like
influenza like respiratory syncytial
virus and other corona viruses you know
Karuna viruses are with us there at
least three four that circulate pretty
regularly that don't cause anything even
close to SARS or or Mars or covert 19
kind of disease and so there is a lot of
seasonality for several respiratory
viruses but we would have been more
certain and with SARS there was some
evidence that some seasonal differential
transmission played a role although
there were other factors in terms of
controlling SARS that was probably more
prominent but the problem with this is
that in 2009 when we had an influenza
pandemic which was a full-on pandemic
there was a new strain of influenza
fortunately it caused relatively low
mortality when we had the influenza
pandemic there was circulation going on
during this summer as well at pretty
decent levels so here's my best educated
guess based on the previous evidence
that we are we could see a diminishing
of transmission as the weather warms up
but we are not necessarily going to see
a vanishing of of this virus so that's
the take or the seasonal fight um thank
you so thank you so much the question
with regard to there are a lot of
questions coming in with regard to a
potential herd immunity with the
population getting it there are a lot of
questions with regard to if you get it
can you be reinfected with it does any
anything along those lines for you dr.
van Ryan you know I think I'm gonna pass
to maybe dr. O'Meara I've seen some one
anecdotal report that you could possibly
be reinfected
but I really can't comment too much on
the herd immunity so the two again two
separate things and actually this time
address both of them but separately so
reinfection part is that look this is a
three four month old virus that's you
know three and a half month old virus we
are still learning about it and our
knowledge has expanded with lightning
speed but we are still understanding
trying to understand that complete
parameters of it what is in our favor in
terms of having at least medium term
immunity is that when they looked at
antibodies they people who got infected
mounted a decent response in terms of
developing antibodies we at this point
do not know it's actually one of the
things that I am working on is to find
what we call a correlative protection
what is the level of antibody at which
you are protected because that's an
important question for vaccine
development it's an important question
for looking at what proportion of your
population is protected etc and so on
and so forth what we do there were a few
reports a couple of case reports that's
indicated that people who were released
from the hospital were then came back
with symptoms they had sort of negative
or two tests and then they came back
that could be not necessarily a
reinfection scenario it could be that
they had initially a virus that was you
know these tests were being developed
etc and it was it happened in situations
where the health system was overwhelmed
that they were incentives to let people
go home it could be that it was an issue
with the testing not necessarily true
reinfection so at this point based on
what we know from other viruses and
based on what we know from the current
data it's reasonable to assume that at
least in the short term and medium term
there will be immunity from this virus
we don't know about so in a lot of virus
as the immunity goes away even without a
mutation
not an influenza-like scenario that we
are looking at but even in viruses don't
that do not mutate first let's say on an
annual basis you sometimes lose immunity
to them but it's not in weeks or months
it's a longer time frame that we are
talking about so in the medium term I
think it's reasonable to assume that we
will have protection if you get it but
the science is evolving
I'd like to pivot to dr. ho in terms of
getting a lot of questions with regard
to the efficacy or success of the actual
treatment that people are recommending
or their reports that their benefits
from in terms of the hydroxychloroquine
plus as this room Ison dose also if you
could touch upon the at-risk populations
and the best things that they can do for
example I've been asked by Susan G Komen
of Philadelphia the CEO their metastatic
breast cancer community and breast
cancer patients in the third and fourth
stage of disease one I know what extra
precautions that they can take being
asked about pregnant women and the
status of any newborns or babies who
have corona virus and being pregnant so
these would be in addition to elderly
and other immune suppressed in areas but
if you could address those two things
about where we are with treatment how
promising it truly is and the and
recommendations for the at-risk
populations I mentioned would be
wonderful
sure well as far as treatment I think
what everybody should know is that you
know it kind of depends on which stats
you read but around 80 to 85 percent of
people they recover completely on their
own just as you would with any other
kind of rash suppori tract infection and
you basically need supportive care and
whether it's some medication to reduce
the fever such as a Tylenol such as
hydrating yourself supportive care and
remaining at home and distancing
yourself from those that you love so
that your loved one at home doesn't get
this infection on the other hand if you
are sick enough to be hospitalized and
these would be higher acuity such as
being shorter breath and requiring
oxygen some people may have chest
discomfort or any kind of
we call alarm signals and for these
people there there are still what we
would say supportive care meaning a
potentially breathing treatment if one
is short of breath potentially the need
for oxygen potentially if one is
dehydrated then fluids and then outside
of those you get into what's called
investigational drugs and and what we
should make clear is that there really
is no fda-approved treatment at this
time there's certainly been a lot of
discussion about potential therapies and
studies in play and different
institutions in the United States that
have used particular drugs and and at
least for what has been looked at is
hydroxychloroquine which has been
studied and has shown to basically have
some promise but it wouldn't be for
everybody because again 80 80 percent of
people who have Cova 19 the completely
recover on their own never require
anything and so what is being discussed
by physicians is the potential role for
hydroxychloroquine in case of there's
increased viral replication to try to
help with kovin 19 there are certainly
other medications that have been
discussed and they all have side effects
right so the the issue with
hydroxychloroquine and azithromycin the
azithromycin is an antibiotic and it
also has different properties such as
anti-inflammation the problem with some
medications is that they can increase
what's called the QTc interval and that
can best be described as when you have
an EKG there's certain spots so there's
like kind of point A to point B and a
point A to point B is too long that's
not good because then your heart rate
can go into an arrhythmia and we
certainly don't want to make things
worse than they already are
and and also I personally I don't feel
it there we still need a data as far as
far as the specific combination of core
of the the with the azithromycin out
sort of that there are still many other
experimental investigational drugs
out there and and you know whether they
truly will work on an investigational
scale I can tell you that as a physician
sometimes one feels compelled to try
something especially if there are those
who have coded 19 have severely severely
sick respiratory illness such as they're
on the ventilator I'm requiring a lot of
oxygen and as this physician you always
want to try something even if it's
investigational and may not be fully
studied as far as you know an awareness
of pregnancy and immuno compromised
these are certainly high risk categories
that you're more likely to get Kovan 19
but you can certainly have a heightened
awareness of how to protect yourself and
you know these are particularly
vulnerable populations anyway and and
the I don't I wouldn't want to call it
the typical cancer patient but you would
imagine that cancer patients often times
may already have a higher understanding
of things like hand hygiene because they
may have you know the need for
chemotherapy with a device that goes
into your chest wall so they're already
thinking of heightened measures to
prevent infection and and and so one of
the possibilities is with social
distancing washing our hands you know if
there are certain errands that need to
be done that would potentially be in a
setting where you would be around crowds
of people such as in a grocery store if
you don't have the someone who's kind of
shop for you or the ability should kind
of get it from outside physical their
patient stores one can always ask for
this you know certainly if somebody is
you know you you are potentially around
somebody who is sick you know the sick
person may be asked to put on a mass or
distance themselves from you these are
some general precautions but even a
greater heightened awareness and if
these individuals need to go there a
doctor
office there are some doctors offices
and more and more it seems where
hospitals clinics etc are considering
the role of telemedicine so that you're
able to connect with your physician
without actually having to physically go
out and about and potentially be around
other people who may just have a common
cold or the flu that as your immunity
means that you may be susceptible to as
far as pregnancy and babies i I have not
heard too much about babies themselves
being infected from but I anecdotally
have heard of perhaps some time after
that when potentially they were exposed
to an adult who was infected and by by
means of contact perhaps the younger
individual might have gotten infected
but kind of leave it there and perhaps
if dr. umar has any further insights as
well I think you covered it and just
this is to come back to what I meant by
a vertical transmission that's what is
meant by vertical transmission from
mother to infant transmission so that
the the reports we have seen do not
indicate that that happens so far the
evidence is good in terms of pregnant
women being at additional risk so yes
they theoretically that could be at a
high risk but the data that has come out
which are very limited have suggested
that they're not at a higher risk of
acquiring that infection but again this
is theoretically there are higher it is
an immune altered state that pregnant
women are in so so it's reasonable to be
a little bit more careful there also I
would add recommendations if a mom were
to test positive to separate the baby
from the mother and things like that so
CDC has good information there are a lot
of organizations to the American Academy
of Pediatrics aap org or the American
College of Obstetricians oncologists as
well have their recommendations so
there's a lot of good useful information
and I'm getting so many questions on so
many topics which is wonderful so one of
the things that I think I'm going to do
I'm going to try
and get to as many as I can on this but
everyone can email me after this webinar
concludes at Yale my email is Yale
alumni Health Network at gmail.com and
if you can email me your questions if
there if you'd like them directed at one
of the specific panelists and indicate
that as well and I will forward and get
back to you with regard to any of the
questions that have not been addressed
at the end of this hour so we will get
to all of your questions I do want to
pivot because one of the greatest
concerns personally professionally
societally is this social distancing
this lockdown everything in terms of
that it's effective there are a lot of
bioethical ramifications of that disease
does not stop because there's
coronavirus so there are many people who
were diagnosed with a cancer a week or
two ago and their treatments are
impaired so I'd love to hear from the
panel with regard to you know every
action has an equal and opposite
reaction and anything that we do do can
have unintended consequences so there
are a lot of discussions happening
around between health care workers the
general public and everyone in terms of
you know ostensibly it becomes a
rationing of care or we are these huge
interventions that we're doing in terms
of calling society to a halt in the
event that there is a case of this
especially since we're not going to ever
be able fully to quantify what the
effects of that are on premature deaths
or worsening of disease that already
exists and other things like that like
we've discussed in terms of the
emotional and psychosocial ramifications
of a lot of the implementations so if we
can talk a little bit about the you know
no death anybody wants no death in
anything but if we can put into context
why some people consider referencing
coronavirus to the flu is a false
equivalence you know touching upon these
different concepts in bioethics of why
we're doing such extreme measures here
because the ramifications can be quite
vast in scope so I'd love to hear
everybody's opinion with regard to those
kinds of issues
um well I can say a couple things about
it you know there are a lot of
implications for social distancing or
our physical justice enas dr. Anwar
likes to to reference it even though I
think that you know it's a hardship on
people I think that the risk that the
disease is progressing right now we're
at a risk of overwhelming the health
care system so I think that if we can
decrease unnecessary social interaction
will actually have the resources
available for the people who need it you
know such as the cancer patient who has
been recently diagnosed or the person
who has a heart attack and needs to be
you know taken to the hospital and put
into the ICU so I think that for the
rest of us you know we don't need to go
out to eat we don't need to you know go
visit all of our friends there's a lot
of things that we don't need to do right
now why this disease is ramping up to
see whether or not we can at least slow
the progression I don't think any of us
thinks it's gonna stop completely
because of this but if we can slow the
progression then hopefully the
healthcare system will be able to
respond those to the sick patients with
the coronavirus and also to the normal
illnesses that society is going to have
because that doesn't stop people still
have babies people still have heart
attacks people still get cancer yeah I
think there as you said there is a
trade-off and it's an unfortunate
trade-off that we find ourselves in in
this position
outbreaks enter these exponential phase
when we talk about non terms of what is
the number of cases we expect we talk in
terms of when the outbreak doubles we
are still testing not enough people to
get the full size but where the testing
has been there doubled the the doubling
time has been 3 to 5 days in terms of
sort of in the exponential phase then it
Peaks for several reasons one is that if
you have impacted enough people then
they are at least transiently protected
and so and so forth and then start
leveling off or your measures are there
so sorry the question was that is this
an infinite
period so we know that at this point it
was because we didn't have we were
flying blind as a country for several
weeks we did not know who everyone's
contact was who presented in the
hospital etc we did not have the tools
or the manpower at the Health Department
if the health departments were saying
that if we do contact tracing meaning
you look at the person who is presenting
at the hospital look go after their
contact how do we test them because we
don't have your prioritizing tests for
patients presenting at a certain level
of disease etc so what is the long-term
how do we it is not sustainable for an
infinite period because they are even if
there were no other competing health
questions which can be in a way you
could argue that if the health system
gets overwhelmed people who are
presenting with heart attack or a stroke
are not going to get treated as well so
that mortality is actually when people
have modeled that it's similar etcetera
or even higher in a in an overflow kind
of a situation but even you said that
aside we are a society that values
health for there other aspects of our
social well-being including the economy
in and of itself and people who sort of
have to go out and learn a daily wage
for example waiters and and those who
work in certain industries construction
workers and so on and so forth we have
to keep that in mind and even otherwise
companies when they continue to thrive
all of us benefit so what is the what do
we do after you have social distancing
that has an impact that doesn't solve
everything
so we've some of I've had some of us
have been thinking and modeling these
things right after these things were put
in place the first thing is that there's
no easy way out the one way you deal
with it is what some places like South
Korea did is that a person presents at
the hospital you can't you trace that
contact for everyone who presents at the
hospital for example and then you go and
test that contacts and then say if that
contact is positive you isolate them so
isolation is for positive cases
and and the other contacts that are not
positive you quarantine them so
quarantine is for those who are not
symptomatic right now so this is to
cover the asymptomatic period as well
and sort of future symptom development
and that kind of stuff and then you look
at the contacts contact that was
positive and say okay how how do you are
they positive or not so you can easily
see what is the problem currently we
don't have enough tests to go to that
level of contact tracing we don't have
the manpower and some of us think the
national level mod mobilization that has
happened in other countries would be
required to that level of aggressive
contact tracing once you do that you
wrap it with up to 75 85 percent then
you can start safely easing of other
restrictions and it's not just the test
part we have a shortage of person
appropriate protective equipment we have
a shortage which I never thought me a
shortage in this country off of swabs in
certain hospitals and so if you want to
use those swabs for sampling during
contact tracing that's the way to do
this so that's one thing the other thing
is there are other aspects to minimize
household level transmission in wuhan
after the restrictions were put in place
79 percent of transmission happened in
the household even in the u.s. is the
first few hundred cases the likelihood
of household transmission is very higher
than outside transmission but we don't
want to be in a situations where
families are ostracizing family members
they are safe safe evidence-based ways
of contributing or caring for family
members CDC has a good set of guidance
for that it includes how to deal with
the laundry how to deal with for
provision of food etc while remaining
compassionate towards our own family
members but that level of education is
not there in the community so we need to
have that as bi covered once we have
that and we this should be a strategy
where we are buying time to put in place
other things that then then at a certain
level of that we should be able to ease
off some of the restrictions but there
will be at least some restrictions with
us for a long term and I don't
people mind having a few restrictions
the concerns are that totals or a near
total shutdown has implications on
people's not just livelihoods but also
lives as well absolutely it increases
stress response which suppresses your
immunity and it's a trajectory that we
don't want people going down and and
many are anyway in terms of that I'm
getting a lot of questions with regard
to there there are many schools have
thought with regard to testing as some
panacea can we get a brief response of
why testing is being constantly shifted
in terms of the life cycle in the
hospital versus these now testing
centers on
Drive Thru testing centers and why the
policy keeps changing maybe dr. ho you
can weigh in on that quickly
yeah sure well one thing for the last
question with the bioethics of you know
people have not having their perhaps
their chemo or something I think it at
some juncture we're going to have to
have sites where you separate the sick
versus a non sick and protect
potentially have independent sites that
work on elective surgery for the not
sick and maybe just kind of separate
them out for to wrap up that part as far
as the testing I mean it keeps shifting
because of a variety of reasons the one
of the rules of the drive-by testing is
to identify those who might have the
illness which may make a difference in
whatever setting they work in so they
know if they have the diagnosis without
kind of putting a burden on any
particular entities such as the
potential for exposure of a sick over 19
patient are potentially sick whose
diagnosis is not yet known to an
outpatient office or to the emergency
department where the potential for
exposure is just a lot greater and so if
you minimize that risk with a one to one
with the in the car and then kind of
their drive-by perhaps you can minimize
that and there are changes as you find
out things such as if the for example
these individual swallows sometimes have
to go into a media that incubates and
that that you use for testing and there
are sometimes shortages of this or that
and this is why many times there are
changes to testing protocols and as it
becomes more urgent to know and
unfortunately sometimes have to
prioritize who might get
and you know it's evolved also as the
disease has where it was just in certain
geographical ericka areas and and then
you could trace back who was more likely
to have Koba 19 and now as we see
community transmission there are
differences in why we might test certain
people I am getting a lot of questions
about how people can help in the
community due to this PPE issue people
are saying certain neighbors are sewing
like crazy with regard to cloth masks
can they use white vinegar as a
disinfectant are these really useful and
valuable substitutes for PPE and are we
how else can we mobilize the people who
are chomping at the bit in isolation
where one of the things that I would
recommend is whatever it is that your
solution that you're trying any problem
that you're trying to attack and solve
make sure that that doesn't undermine
your initial social isolation so we
don't want someone to solve one problem
but by creating another problem so if
everybody could touch on final thoughts
of how everyone in society can help in
terms of doing their part because we all
together can really make tremendous
inroads I would love to hear final
thoughts from each of you with regard to
that I think from the PPE standpoint
there are obviously a lot of dire needs
in many cases and many times it depends
on the individual Hospital as far as for
example some are accepting donations but
donations of unused supplies that have
been approved such as n95 masks that
were unused but we're used by a
different you know store or a different
clinic that now is not kind of mobilized
and so forth you know as far as things
that people can make the answer is it
depends because your intention is great
but certainly some kind of mask is
better than no mask at all but whether
it will actually afford the protection
if you that's all you have that's that's
not as clear sometimes so you know
and whereas there are other things that
one might need to consider if there is a
shortage of thing other things like
gowns and kind of those facials that you
might see and these are things to
consider in a ways that we never thought
about and and I think the mobilization
will depend on where the committee's are
what is accepted by the local hospitals
or the EMS and so on and each of these
will potentially have their own ideas on
what is accepted and and what they would
kind of not be able to use at the moment
dr. van Ryan um well I would echo what
Cindy said in terms of the fact that
we're not really sure of the homemade
masks are really going to be sufficient
to protect the healthcare workers they
may be more useful in a family situation
that somebody's actually trying to cover
their own cough you know for instance
you would use a tissue you might have a
mask or something if somebody's coming
to care for a family member who has
coughing but and I think the jury is
really out as to whether or not they're
going to be that effective I think one
of the things we can do though as a
community is you know - we have lots of
social media and we have FaceTime and
Internet and we can check on our friends
and see how they're doing there's lots
of ways that we can help friends who
might need supplies or might need an
errand run for them or just might need
to talk to somebody if they feel like
they're isolated and I think there ways
that we can do that even if we are in
relative physical isolation so we
shouldn't forget that we are still
connected dr. Elmer yes so I'll take the
last one or two minutes - - that's
something coming up on the the questions
and identify in the interest to fight
time I didn't address the herd immunity
you think that people were talking about
especially there was an op-ed by someone
who used to be you know a physician who
used to be affiliated with Yale up until
a few years ago in an adjunct position
and and sort of that is a version of a
UK former UK model which said that let
everyone get infected who's not in the
really high-risk group and will develop
a herd immunity and the rest will be
protected
it's not you know those of us who both
work on the quantitative side and also
in the field find that a little bit
concerning to be honest
you notice that a lot of these ideas are
not coming from infectious disease
epidemiologists even if there is you
know people who contribute as for
example nutritional scientists etc
that's you know the contributions and
everyone has a voice but those of us who
actually deal with these issues not you
know starting three months ago have a
little bit of concern I've pushed
towards that strategy that's why the UK
government abandoned that strategy I do
feel that there is and my understanding
is there's there should be something
coming out in the New York Times you
know focusing on are some of the more
mainstream approaches Mike you know I
think our focus should be how do we
safely reduce these restrictions based
on some of the things that I I mentioned
there's no shortcuts there one of the
things that I would come back to what my
colleagues mentioned is there these two
outbreaks one outbreak is of the virus
and the other one is for misinformation
and one way of dealing with this is to
sort of filter the information but also
a lot of scientists who were very
passive on social media have taken time
and God knows those of us who are
actually doing active research don't
have the bandwidth to do this but go on
social media do events like this my
twitter handle is Saad Omer 3o m ER 3
and so if you feel free to follow me and
there are many others who are even you
know sort of more effective in conveying
factual information thank you so much
everyone you're all amazing and to
everyone who's following here we're
gonna be having more yale events we'll
send out a link to this video hopefully
later today to the attendees of this
event and you can certainly forward it
to anybody who think it would be helpful
so that they can get good information I
have a litany of questions I ask all of
you to email me at my email again as
Yale alumni how
network at gmail.com Yale alumni Health
Network at gmail.com and I can forward
to the different panelists if you have a
preference of a question we'll figure
out a way to get those to you
Yann has a Twitter page at Yale Health
sig at Yale health s IG I'm on Twitter
at Jamie Wells mdj mie wel s md you can
independently follow any of my personal
accounts from facebook to linkedin to
whatever to get questions to me if you
forget the email address thereafter I
will get anything to the panelists that
anyone has a request of so I can I can
do that and again our email is Yale
alumni Health Network at gmail.com there
are so many questions things are
evolving we hope that you are empowered
by the information today this is you can
absolutely take healthful steps try to
be in the moment to focus on the good
things that the that do abound in life
you know it is a wonderful opportunity
to check in on neighbors if you have a
skill set or service that you can
voluntarily use every person has
individual values that can contribute to
helping this problem whether if you're
an entertainer make people laugh there
are so many modes of communication for
that so the mental health physical
health economic health all of these
things are intertwined to get us past
this critical point and we thank you all
for attending and again it's not over
there are going to be other events we're
gonna probably do another one and in
addition you can reach out yellow alumni
health network at gmail.com thank you so
much